Game of Thrones seasons 1 to 6 in 5
minutes Robert Baratheon rules the realm
of Westeros he deposed the dragon
dynasty and married a Lannister Cersei
who breeds a brood of bastards with her
brother Jaime who breaks Browns back to
keep the secret lady cat captures Tyrion
falsely accuses him lesser tries to make
him fly the bronze blade excuses him Ned
stunts seed that the seed is strong
sweet rice I told Bobby but is God by
books of Cersei so Ned tries to set [ __ ]
straight but Baelish betrays him and Ned
gets beheaded on the steps of bail or
Sept young Robb gathers the banners
battle south and his crown diet rains
and runs away Sansa suffers jaw from the
Hound while John Janzen watch on the
wall will winter is falling in wildlings
are calling in walkers are stalking in
dead men walking
Dany weds Drogo her brother goes Loco
crowned with gold oh and Drogo dies -
Danny raises a pyre and Stratton to fire
and rises as the mother of dragons
Robb battles Lannisters falls in love
with Tallis er which breaks his oath to
Walder Frey and he ain't bloody heaven
that Theon takes a boat to Balaam turns
his cloak to make him Greyjoy takes
Winterfell loses it and Ramsay snow
abuses him bran and Rickon get away bran
goes with dojin there's a crow while
Stannis claims the Iron Throne though
he's claims denied by his bro Saran
Lee's shanked by a shadow fight from the
vagina of a precess of fire Sanus then
sails for black would obey but he said a
flame and as the day Tyrion loses face
vessel of Bechet at the end of the day
so it's okay
Isle walks with yarn but she's caught
and hauled to Harrenhal it's awful but
she's supported by an assassin called
Jack and hugger Dany walks the waist and
talks thirteen cathain to let her into
the city goes to a party asks for an
Army's R&P opry steal a dragon so she
goes with home the undying gets high and
kills a guy with fire while the Watchmen
walk beyond the wall and corn for Sir
John to turn his cloak to the free folk
so while the watch is fighting whites
and things strong spooning ginger
wildlings hashtag no regrets also
there's an army of the Dead
cat Sims Jamie with brilliant to the
south and lock captures them and lops
off Jamie's hand pouch the phrase get
fed up sir Rob gets read wedded killing
cat and tell us awhile add meals getting
bedded Eyre is captured by Bros with no
banners the Hound fight sapphire night
arises after battle aya takes flight but
is caught by sound or who holds around
the Riverlands hoping for a ransom Jon
meets mance the wild linking finding for
free folk they climbed the wall jump
hills a walk then goes back to the
Nights Watch Danny gets unsullied sell
me Daario miss and I and liberates the
slave cities of a stupor and Yong Chi
Joffrey dies from Tyrell wine another
wedding
another dead King says he blames a
brother Tyrion in his trial the Viper
fights firm Oberyn dies and so does Greg
the Qyburn Mexico gain on dead Jaime
saves Tyrion who slayed Shane Tywin the
spider Varys sends the dwarf across to
Pentos Sansa leaves the city with Petyr
Littlefinger who lies wife's Lysa that
makes a fly the Irie
I wonder surround sound or kill some
people who had wronged tohum gets bit by
black or by default - Brienne when he
fights her iodine ice and/or mercy shows
iron to take a boat east while the
Nights Watch fight wildlings and Karl
fukken Tana Jung goes out beyond the
wall in his head by King Stannis Danny T
captures marine locks up a dragons to
make peace
Sansa marries Ramsay the North remembers
and forgets she jumps the walls of
Winterfell which is on Saved by Brie
aunt Mel tells Stannis burn your
daughter and it's done then Stannis and
his army slaughtered by Ramsay Bolton
Cersei tries to frame the Tyrells ends
up walking with a shame bail now she's
gonna bloody pay hill on the high and
mighty Sparrow Jaime comes to Dorne with
Bronn to save his daughter auntie gets
caught up with the bahraini entitled
spout bad [ __ ] I arrives at Braavos
joins the house of black and white she
lands till I loses a side so that she
might become no.1 Jon Snow wins a vote
goes to hardhome get some free folk on a
boat then he gets stabbed
Dany fights insurgency from the sons of
the harpy tries a pit fight in a
marriage but they both go pretty badly
so she flies away on a dragon Sansa
escapes from Winterfell and makes her
way north to the wall where the red
which is raising Jon who kills his
killers watch is done Ramsay Bolton
expands his hold on the lot of the
northern kingdom so Jon marches armies
bastard Bowl is on the good guys won
higher trains plays sage lady crane
slays the waif displays a face escapes
the faceless bakes of it so rates of
Frey and say she's is stark the Ravens
training brand to see through Trey's
magic abilities zombies almost killed
them all but Hodor holds the door Ben
saves bran and Meera then says see you
bran sees a secretly Anna's John's mum
while the Hound rooms around the
Riverlands joins the brothers Mary bad
Jaime and Bronn brick Riverrun blackfish
would rather die than run Sam and Gilly
go to horn Hill meet Sam's [ __ ]
father Randall they go to Old Town
taking hot Spain to learn some stuff
from the maesters Cersei burns the
sparrows Tyrells all her enemies and
then because her son is dead declares
herself the Queen Doran slaughtered by
sand snakes so Elena forges calls with
Dawn and Dany against Circe's order
setting stage for massive war and Danny
goes back to Vaes Dothrak barbecues a
persecutors takes a khalasar and marches
to marine she breaks the siege with fire
makes fast friends of Theon Yara and
finally after all these years heads west
to Westeros
thanks for watching if you'd like some
slightly more detailed gameofthrones
explanations and analyses please
subscribe and check out our other videos
thanks also to Random House for sending
us one of their new limited-edition
george RR martin boxes this is not a
paid promo but the box is pretty cool
it's got a beautiful illustrated edition
of the first game of Thrones book and
the Game of Thrones card game which is
fun and a nice map and a heap of other
stuff so if you'd like to buy one of
these boxes there is a link in the
description below finally thanks to the
patrons supporting this channel on
patreon the patreon is currently paused
and no one is being charged for the rest
of the year because old chip Tex is
taking some time off we'll be back in
2017 with heaps of new Game of Thrones
videos and maybe also some Westworld
stuff we have been reading your comments
so thanks again and until then have a
good one